derrière moi nous 24 conquêtes de la
coupe stanley mais il y aurait pu en
avoir une 25e
après avoir vaincu ottawa quatre
victoires contre une dans la finale de
l'est le 6 mars 1919 les joueurs du
canadien vont voyager durant six jours
pour se rendre à seattle afin de débuter
la finale de la coupe stanley contre les
métropolitaines les joueurs arriveront
fatigué lors du premier match le 19 mars
1919 seattle écrasera le canadien 7 à 0
on sait que à l'époque le hockey à
répondre un joueur violent avec ses skis
jouets peluches des substituts mais
généralement loué match 60 minutes
c'était terrible c'était la norme
après cinq matches âprement disputé
c'est l'égalité entre les deux équipes
deux victoires de chaque côté et une
partie nulle mais dans le vestiaire du
canadien plusieurs joueurs commencent à
avoir des malaises
c'est la grippe espagnole
une pandémie qui sera dévastatrice au
canada au canada elle est la source de
tant de morts que la grande guerre donc
autour de 50 mille morts à l'échelle du
pays
quatorze mille morts à l'échelle du
québec et à montréal même plus de 3600
morts donc c'est une épidémie ou
pandémie qui est extrêmement importante
et qui est lié de manière très intime à
la mobilisation des soldats et des
civils pour la grande guerre
on avait beaucoup d'institutions au
québec aussi à l'époque des collèges les
orphelinats des hôpitaux est donc encore
une fois c'est la promiscuité c'est la
proximité avec d'autres qui facilite la
transmission de la maladie puis
l'annoncé ce qui s'est passé aussi dans
le vestiaire du canadien de montréal
quoi j'ai sûrement cette man et mais
plusieurs joueurs qui étaient pas en
mesure de jouer notamment joe roth qui
lui de joueurs des canadiens et qui
décédera des suites de la grippe
espagnole six jours plus tard et il ya
quand même cinq joueurs au total des
canadiens qui ont été hospitalisés si
bien que le propriétaire de l'équipe
john kennedy a demandé la permission à
l'équipe de seattle d'utiliser des
joueurs de vancouver
et si hâte aux artistes et que c'est
apprendre une bonne idée pour eux parce
qu'on aurait évidemment pris les
meilleurs joueurs de vancouver
donc ils ont refusé et finalement les
instances on peut entendre ont décidé
que il valait mieux éliminer a fait
annuler sur glace et ce sera donc la
seule fois dans l'histoire le 30 mars
1919 que la coupe stanley sera
interrompu et jamais attribué il faudra
attendre la grève des joueurs en 2004
pour que le trophée si convoité ne soit
pas remis du tout aujourd'hui 24 coupes
trône dans la vitrine du canadien
la 25e se fait toujours attendre robert
frosi radio canada montréal